So the wakeup tree for the MCS barrier
is a binary wakeup tree. Once again here, there's
a theoretical result that backs this particular choice
that the shortest critical path from the root to
the last awakened child, is shortest when you
have a binary wakeup tree, and that's the reason
that... They chosen to have this construction. Even
though the arrival tree's a [INAUDIBLE] tree. The construction
for the wake up tree is a binary
tree. And let me explain the construction of this
binary wake up tree. Every processor is assigned
a unique spot again. So P 0 the root
And uh,P1, P2 over here, P3, P4, P5,
P6, and P7 So that completes the eight processes
for this binary tree set-up for wakeup. And the
latest structure that is used in the wakeup tree
is as a child pointer data structure. And
the ChildPointer data structure is essentially a way by
which a parent can reach down to the
children and indicate that that it is time to
wake up. So, that's the purpose of this
ChildPointer data structure. And, once again, as you can
see, depending on the particular location in this
wakeup tree, they may have children, they may not
have children. So, P0 has two children, P1 has two children, P3 and P4. P2
has two children, P5 and P6. P3 had one child, P7, and that is it. Because you
have a processors, and these guys. Don't have any children P4, P5, and P6. So in
terms of wake up, what is going to happen
is that when everybody arrives at the barrier P0
is going to be noticing it, and through the
arrival tree. And so now it says oh, it's
time now to wake up everybody, and the way
it does that, it has a specific pointer To reach
into P1 and signal to P1 that it's time
to wake up. And similarly it has a specific pointer
in, in, in, in P2 to wake up. So
a particular memory location, which is a pointer to a
location that this guy's waiting on to wake up.
So it's going to do that. And so what is
going on is that agian, this is another important
point that in order to, to know that it is
time to wake up, each one of these processes
is standing on a statically determined location. P2 is
standing on a particular location here, and, and P1
is standing on a particular location here. And so when
P0 signals P1 it is exactly sending a signal
to P1 and it is not affecting any of the other processes. And similarly, when it
signals P2 it signals exactly P2 using this pointer. And
similarly, once P1 and P2 are woken up. They can march down the tree
and signal P3 and P4, and signal P5 and P6
by using the, the statically assigned spots that
the children are spinning on to indicate that it
is time to wake up. So, the key point I want to stress again is the fact
that. In this construction of the tree, by
design. We make sure that we know a position
in the tree and we know exactly the,
the memory location that we have to spin on,
in order to know that it is time to wake up. So these red arrows show the
specific location that is associated with each one
of these processors In the wakeup tree. So once
the parents signal the children and they marched
down and signal all the other children, then at
that point, everybody's awake, and the barrier has
been reached. So the key take, take away points
with the MCS tree barrier is that the wakeup tree is binary. The arrival tree
is forwarding and the static locations associated
with each processor, both in the arrival tree
that we saw earlier, and the /?
tree. And through the specific statically assigned spot
that each processor can spin on, we
are making sure that the amount of contention
on the network is limited. And also by
packing the variables into a single data structure
we can make sure that the contention for
shared locations is minimized as neat as possible.